[Music]
to know if the crystals of salts are
really dry let's perform a quick
experiment all we would need for this
experiment is a burner a test tube and a
test tube holder we would also need a
few crystals of copper sulfate before we
begin our experiment could you tell me
the color of the crystals yes it's blue
the crystals look dried don't they but
are they really dry let's find out now
let's add these crystals in this dry
test tube and heat it what do you notice
after some time you notice that the
color of the crystals don't greyish
white and did you observe the water
droplets on the test you why does this
happen it's because when copper sulfate
is heated it loses its water molecules
and that's why it turns greyish white in
color when it's dry it's referred to as
anhydrous copper sulfate and what do you
think will happen when we add water to
it again after adding water to anhydrous
copper sulfate it becomes blue again the
chemical formula for hydrated copper
sulfate is cuso4 dot v h2o yes there are
five water molecules you can see this
water is called the water of
crystallization water of crystallization
is the fixed number of water molecules
present in one formula unit of the salt
so we can say that five water molecules
are present in one formula unit of
copper sulfate and when heated it loses
its water molecules another example is
that of ferrous sulphate it has a green
color
due to the presence of seven water
molecules in it so though the crystals
look dry they aren't really dry another
salt which possesses water of
crystallization is gypsum it's a
hydrated salt of calcium and it's
chemical formula is caso4 dot 2 h2o what
is it used for
when we heat gypsum at 373 Kelvin it
loses its water molecules to give us
plaster of Paris have you heard of
plaster of Paris before yes
it's a substance which doctors use as a
support for fractured bones it's also
used in the construction industry and in
making casts for statues and also making
designer for ceilings
its chemical name is calcium sulphate
Hemi hydrate and its chemical formula is
this caso4 and half a molecule of water
after addition of water plaster of Paris
is again converted into gypsum okay are
you wondering how we were able to see
just half a water molecule here is that
possible it's written like this because
to formula units of cash himself weight
share one water molecule and why do you
think it's called
plaster of Paris does it have anything
to do with the city named Paris in
France plaster of Paris was first made
many many years ago and has been used by
ancient Egyptian and Roman civilizations
however it wasn't used on a large scale
until the 17th century when it was
required to be used in almost all the
construction in Paris in the year 1666 a
fire raged across London destroying many
parts of it in its aftermath the King of
France ordered that all walls made of
wood in Paris be immediately covered
with plaster as a protection against
such fires this resulted in large-scale
mining of gypsum which was available
around Paris in huge quantities thus
during the early 18th century Paris
became the center of plaster production
and hence the name plaster of Paris
[Music]